the fact vaccines need police escorts is
a sign of their value
[Music]
commodity that also goes to waste
as much as 30 percent of vaccines are
thrown away in some countries
the reasons vary storage and logistical
challenges as well as the type of vials
and syringes used
but Innovations could end the waste
I'm Ben fazulin nice to have you along
some countries have had to throw away
thousands of Jabs others like Finland
are fine-tuning their vaccine campaigns
to ensure every last drop counts it's
putting the nation way ahead of others
at this vaccination center around 3 000
doses are prepared and administered
every day it's around 40 percent more
than should be possible with the
supplies available that is because a
Finnish invention makes it possible to
make a little bit of vaccine go a long
way
the person behind the creation is Nurse
sari Rose who was among those starting
covet vaccinations in December last year
we don't want to throw away any viable
vaccine and it has become Paramount to
use the vaccines as economically as
possible especially after some of them
were limited to certain age groups only
Bruce Works in a public hospital but
volunteered to do extra vaccination
shifts
she fine-tuned her technique within the
first few days of preparing the doses
once I noticed that exchanging the
syringes and getting rid of excess air
in the equipment guaranteed two extra
doses of vaccine I sent an email to our
medical director
he quickly contacted Health authorities
about it
everybody was very excited
Bruce's technique requires syringes with
a one millimeter capacity and small
scale the syringe is first filled with
vaccine but just enough to get the
required vaccine dose in addition a bit
of air is drawn from the vile Bottle
Into the syringe finally the air and
vaccine inside the syringe need to swap
places before the vaccine is
administered
the air bubble technique maximizes the
amount of vaccine that is extracted from
each vial for instance it makes it
possible to prepare seven instead of
five biotech doses as well as 12 instead
of 10 AstraZeneca doses Health experts
made roses technique their official
recommendation for covid vaccinations in
the country in January
despite its benefits Norway is the only
country to follow finland's footsteps
medical director Timo carpean from the
city of Helsinki so far hasn't had the
time to advertise the method globally
some teaching materials have only
recently been translated into English
I think this technique can be copied to
other countries too to be able to
vaccinate 40 percent more people than
originally projected is simply
incredible
Roboto for the world to reopen however
it is not enough to vaccinate people in
just one country while Nations such as
Finland are continuously easing
restrictions other parts of the world
are only starting their own vaccination
campaigns
Helsinki City medical director Timo Lu
Karen and joins us so Timo should the
rest of the world be watching our show
very closely today
truly we are we are in a direct dire
need of vaccines and of course every
every vaccine counts explain to us again
then how exactly this works you're
talking about Precision equipment uh but
getting the right type of equipment is
extremely important starting with what
sort of syringe do we need I know there
are different sorts of syringes with low
Dead Space others with high Dead Space
so a lot of that vaccine gets wasted it
gets stuck either in the syringe or in
the needle itself what sort of syringe
do we need first of all
uh we thought it was technique it's it's
actually a bit easier you only need
small enough syringes one milliliter
syringe is enough because uh at the end
uh when given when the vaccine is given
the data space can be kind of
um it doesn't matter when you have the
air bubbling over there to be used to
push out the vaccine from the syringe
and then what sort of a needle do you
need
uh it's a it's a small well basically
it's it's smaller smallest possible
neither nilowatt which can handle the
the vaccine itself so small diameter but
long enough to uh be able to give it
continuously so uh there's not a lot of
uh problem with the needle in a way and
what about when it comes to the vial
that that you get the actual vaccine in
yes the vials are are a little bit
different story uh first of all if it's
of course you have to be uh uh good with
the hygiene but on the other hand
there's a different amount of doses in
each vial you might get six you might
get eight so you have to be precise that
you you for every dose you take every
vaccine you create from the multidos
vials you make sure that that every
every vaccination every jab you're going
to the gifts to the patients are truly
full uh so that you give the precise
dose so you cannot accept uh kind of a
uh a little less than the precise amount
of dosing if if there's not enough for
six doses then there's not enough so
there are so many little steps where
this could go wrong
um and we're talking about human error
here why not just go for a single dose
vial uh where it's all pre-measured and
pre-dosed and and you have nothing to
worry about
well multi-dose vials are much easier to
produce I think and as well as the
distribute or around it globally so uh
we would prefer uh pre-made a pre-dosed
syringes and and uh pre with needles in
inserted already but there's not there's
no such things at the moment available
for college yeah
um it's all a Race Against Time uh in
the meantime can other countries I mean
is there anything holding back other
countries from repeating what you guys
are doing replicating the method that
you've discovered
I don't think so it's basically all that
you need is the rights equipment precise
working and and uh the process around
the uh around the uh the
vaccination Center that you get to uh
take care that you have the precise
amount of the type kind of the patients
you are vaccinating there's enough of
them as well because if you if you count
that there's only five doses coming from
the vial and you get six and you only
have five patients coming in then the
one dose gets wasted anyways so you have
to take care that there's also patients
around
it's also a lot to call for now but for
other vaccines for Global best practice
is there a possibility of maybe someday
seeing that needles the the right
needles are always used the right
syringes are also used that we we get
some sort of global best practice
uh definitely in a way if we use this
multi-dose vials but when it comes to
pre uh pre-manufactured uh uh syringes
with needles attached Etc there's no not
much to do anymore but if you use
multi-dose vials then of course this
kind of a technique can be applied to
different sorts of vaccines as well
okay fantastic to have you on the show
today Timo Lu Karen Helsinki City
medical director and excellent news and
nice insights about that Local Hero of
yours you'll have to pass on my
congratulations
thank you we will
now here's Derek Williams with his take
on vaccines vials and waste our viewer
question
why aren't injected vaccines
manufactured as a single unit instead of
having the vaccine and the syringe
separate
this is a great question one that I've
never really actually considered before
um right now most vaccine manufacturers
are are filling and shipping multi-dose
vials of vaccine that contain between 5
and 15 doses on site at the vaccination
Center or at the doctor's office
staff then have to painstakingly draw
them into syringes and in a complex
time-consuming series of steps where
where a lot could actually go wrong due
to human error and and there are a lot
of other issues with the bile system not
least that once the seal on one has been
broken all of the doses in the vial have
to be used quickly leftovers can't just
be stuck back in the fridge for use
later so so since everyone is getting
their own syringe anyway why aren't
machines just pre-filling them directly
as a single unit instead of putting
large batches of doses in vials first
pre-filled single shot syringes are
already the norm in some parts of the
world for for vaccinations against other
pathogens but but there appear to be two
primary reasons why the older vile
system has been the method of choice so
far for the mass covid-19 vaccine
rollout the first
is speed with manufacturers churning out
hundreds of millions of doses it's
simply faster for them to squirt 10 at a
time into a single vial than it is to
fill 10 separate syringes and with the
pandemic in full swing getting as much
vaccine as possible out there has been
vital and a second factor is cost until
now
single dose pre-filled syringes have
been more expensive to produce but but
many manufacturers say that's changing
and that that pre-filling syringes is
actually more efficient because then you
don't need millions of medical grade
glass vials so so when demand for
covid-19 vaccines begins to slow I think
that you can expect pre-filled syringes
to grow in popularity because they have
so many advantages
foreign
[Music]
stories making news Indonesia has
reported a record increase of 1025
covert deaths that brings the total
number of fatalities to more than 71 000
the Southeast Asian country has been
struggling to cope with a new wave of
infections
and the fisa biontech covered vaccine is
on track to become the first foreign jab
approved in China Chinese Regulators
have completed an expert review of the
MRNA vaccine China looks said to use the
drug as a booster for those who've
received two shots of homemade vaccines
thanks for watching stay safe and see
you again soon